what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so it seems like an eternity but we
are covering the hunt for Wolverine now
this is a one shot those three guys who
are new to comics and you don't really
know what a one-shot means different
publishers treated different ways but
by-and-large a one shot is basically a
way of saying like here is the new
direction quote-unquote that like either
an entire publication house like Marvel
and DC is going in or a series is going
in like the uncanny x-men heroic age
one-shot or like the New Avengers
Illuminati one-shot or something like
that
sometimes publishers will use it as a
way to like test something out right
like the New Avengers Illuminati one
shot that was originally just one comic
and it proved to be incredibly popular
and so we got a miniseries based out of
it if it it proved to be even more
popular which it did then we get a whole
ongoing series out of it which is
Jonathan Hickman's New Avengers vol 3
and so with this whole thing that goes
on with this take for example like DC
rebirth like we got DC Universe rebirth
number one that's a one-shot it's
designed to basically say here's the new
direction of DC Comics going forward to
however long it is until we change
things up again I don't know but this is
basically designed to say like here's
where Wolverine stands right now now
following this and what Marvel's gonna
do is they're gonna do like the where is
Wolverine and it's gonna be a series of
mini series so it's gonna be like like
like I think four four part series if I
remember correctly and then there's also
like this story that has like all the
little mini stories of Wolverine at the
end of like all these comics they're all
going to be put together into one big
story so it's kind of a big deal and and
truth to tell if I'm being honest I
actually think the return of Wolverine
and all the things that are building up
to it are gonna prove to be if not
already like more popular than like
Marvel's infinity summer event because
the infinity stories have been done to
death like there's so many infinity
stories but like Wolverine returning to
them to Marvel Comics is a big deal like
people are pretty hyped about I'm pretty
excited about it to see what direction
they go in but initially what we do here
is we pick up with a group called the
Reavers in Alberta Canada now this is
cool because what this does is this
throws back to the old Chris Claremont
uncanny x-men like 247 to 249 I think
don't take that as an absolute truth I'm
probably wrong so here was the whole
idea
the Reavers originally back in like
uncanny x-men 229 I think it was they
were originally just like a group of
people who were like criminals more or
less they were small-time villains what
Claremont did is he basically took the
character of Donald Pierce who was a
member of the Hellfire Club and launched
a set of Reavers on
him now the way the Clermont did thing
this is the important thing to bear in
mind and as much as I would love to I've
always wanted to go back and cover like
the whole chris claremont seventeen-year
one of the x-men because it's my
favorite era of all time but it is 17
years of comics and that's just an
ridiculous attempt like I don't even
know if that would ever work the whole
thing is that he would go through and he
would he would like introduce characters
and particular roles like the Hellfire
Club was just like you had the main
Hellfire Club and then you had the inner
circle by and large they're used
interchangeably like if you're standing
in a line at a comic book store and
somebody references the Hellfire Club
they're talking about the inner circle
is basically what it means but what you
had is you it was basically modeled
after like chess pieces you had the
white King you had the black King you
had the White Queen you had the black
Queen so on and so forth black Bishop
white Bishop II was modeled after an
actual chessboard Donald Pierce was the
black Bishop non sorry I think he was
the white Bishop maybe he was a black
Bishop I remember anyway he was like
like third or fourth in line and in like
you know the hierarchy of the Hellfire
Club the issue with this is that the way
that his character was done he basically
hated mutants and the idea was that
because the Hellfire Club was composed
of mutants he was essentially a part of
the group in order to try to like
destroy it from the inside out as well
as like go on to take out various you
know mutants that existed out in the
world things like that eventually he was
ousted from the team and that was
Claremont's way of like removing Donald
Pierce from the Hellfire Club and then
spinning him off into his own stories to
see if they would succeed and they
actually did the Reavers under Donald
Pierce were actually pretty cool like
they were pretty amazing a lot of this
of a lot of what you're seeing here is a
throwback to the old Chris Claremont
stuff and that's why it works because
it's a lot of the same people that were
there before like pretty boy skull
Smasher like these guys who were old
school going all the way back now the
idea is that this kind of continues on
to like the most logical conclusion of
Chris Claremont run so basically at this
point in time Donald Pierce's Reavers
are essentially just like guns for hire
but they've consistently failed so
they're basically they're basically
screw-ups and this is like their last
big job but because of the fact of the
Reavers are cyborgs what they do is they
basically take these jobs in an effort
to like upgrade themselves and we'll
actually talk about the importance of
that here in a second but the overall
goal is for them to essentially like
take the adamantium statue of Wolverine
and then in turn sell it now the reason
why this matters is because remember
Wolverine died because he was encased in
adamantium and his healing factor
stopped working as well because his
healing factor stopped working he was
basically a human that was covered in
metal he basically suffocated now that
is a legitimate way to kill Wolverine if
you take Wolverine and use
to the water and you leave him there
he'll suffocate and he'll die his body
won't adapt he won't learn how to
breathe underwater
he'll just drown and he'll die and
that'll be the end of him but Wolverine
is basically dead for all intents and
purposes and so with this in mind there
are two main goals of the Reavers here
the first is to remove Wolverine from
the adamantium and the second is to sell
off both because the body of Wolverine
is worth a fortune
but adamantium itself is worth so much
money
I mean if it's the hardest metal in the
world and there really is no more
adamantium anymore I mean the loss of
the adamantium was used to encase
Wolverine and so what they've stumbled
into you hear what they've come across
is the last bit of adamantium combined
with Wolverines body being stored inside
both of which can be sold off for a
fortune the problem with this is that
security has been installed a year which
you've figured they would have suspected
but they didn't ah they just kind of
broke in and then of course they end up
hearing a bamf that's the presence of
Nightcrawler and the x-men immediately
start responding now this is a cool
moment here this is well reasons why I
love this so much
by and large when the x-men fight
against various villains throughout your
entire publication history when they're
fighting against various villains it's
usually in like a city or something like
that or it's out in space or something
along those lines in this instance
they're out in the middle of nowhere
Kitty Pryde kind of comments on this and
it's like there's no one here for miles
we can literally cut loose we can do
whatever we want to here and this is
actually the best case scenario for the
x-men and the worst case scenario for
the Reavers because remember with
everything that's been going on with the
x-men so far there's a lot of pent-up
aggravation here and if they can take
that out on the Reavers then like then
then woe betide them now the other part
of this is we actually do this a little
bit of a flashback and this is pretty
important here because what we find out
is that after the death of Wolverine a
lot of people started showing up to pay
the respect that you wouldn't expect
here one of them was Reed Richards now
again when Wolverine lost his healing
factor it was due to a other dimensional
virus that he had basically basically
contracted but with his healing factor
being shut down he started going to a
veritable who's who of the Marvel
Universe Reed Richards Tony Stark your
standard run-of-the-mill genius people
and said is there a way for you to turn
it back on Reed Richards almost feels a
little bit of guilt here because there
was no conceivable way for him to do it
but he also didn't apply like all of his
resources to it and that's one of the
reasons why he said why he feels a
little bit of guilt here is because if
he had put everything in the world aside
and said we're gonna figure out how to
restore your healing factor there's a
chance it may have worked but Reed
didn't and the result is that he feels a
little bit of guilt over this at the
same time as people like Cyclops
remember Wolverine
by cops historically always had this
kind of love triangle going on with Jean
Grey that Cyclops was in love with Jean
Grey Jean Grey was in love with Cyclops
but she also taught a harbored feelings
for Wolverine that's the old Chris
Claremont story but over the years
despite this love triangle they they had
been involved in there was a lot of
respect between the two of them you know
they kind of hated each other to a
degree but they also respected the other
for what it is that they had done over
the course of their lives and the work
that they had put in but that all came
to a head during schism and Wolverine
formed the Jean Grey school of higher
learning and Cyclops stayed with the
Xavier Institute and they went on to
raise their own two separate groups of
x-men but with that in mind like Cyclops
it still kind of says look like there
are things that I should have said here
there are things that I should have told
them that I never told them before and
so in this instance where they kind of
asks a question like should we really
just leave him here like this because
somebody will stumble across it it's
inevitable somebody will learn about
this somewhere along the line and when
they do they're probably gonna try to
steal should we leave him like this is
this what he would want
or should we find a different way and
the question is well I mean we could
find a different way but like how do we
get Wolverine out of adamantium it's
literally the hardest metal in the in
the universe and that's when Colossus
pops up and says okay like I have a
different idea like I have I have an
idea on what we can do to pull this off
now Jemmy back to the present day this
is what makes the Reavers so dangerous
so the x-men powers don't change I mean
they can like like you know Grant
Morrison during his run on new x-men
introduced the idea of secondary
mutations they kind of happen to a
degree under Chris Claremont but it was
like a once in a million kind of thing
like it almost never happened worth
Grant Morrison it was like well now it
happens more frequently Emma Frost gets
her diamond form different things like
that
and so because x-men's powers almost
never change they're by and large easy
to defeat if you know how to counter
their powers but with Reavers it's
completely different and it's kind of a
checks and balances and trade-off most
Reavers are nowhere near as powerful as
the x-men but the Reavers powers can
change they can upgrade they can modify
one day or Weaver might be able to
control some you know magnetism on a
small level the next day he he can
control fire that's how the the Reavers
function and formed and that's why they
were always so interesting is because in
the old Claremont stories when the
Reavers popped up you never knew what
power they were gonna have he didn't
really know like what the 'change would
they modified and that's what gets hit
on here it's kind of like we don't
really know what to expect every fight
with the Reavers has to be treated as a
brand new fight because you don't know
what they're gonna be capable of this
time around but again like you got guys
like Colossus you know the osmium
organic skin like this guy is
virtually indestructible for depending
on who it is at he's fighting I mean
world where Hulk of course broke his
arms but still like when it comes to the
Reavers there's no real chance for them
to be able to take him out and so he's
literally going through alongside the
other x-men and just crushing these guys
bit by bit piece by piece now while
that's happening Donald Pierce alongside
one of the other Reavers is basically
breaking into the adamantium body or the
atom an adamantium statue of Wolverine
because that reader has the ability to
manipulate the atomic structure of
matter and that's what ends up happening
once they break through it what we end
up finding out is this empty there's
nothing in there Wolverine is not inside
that adamantium case and so that's when
people start to panic because they're
like well then where the hell did he go
like IV what happened he obviously
didn't break out because the things not
damaged so if he's not in there then
what happened to him and so what we end
up doing is jumping back to the Past
again and we pick up with Kitty Pryde
now this is genius this is one of the
smartest things and it's truth like I
want it like I wouldn't say that I asked
the question why didn't they do this but
I don't think I did like I can't take
credit for that but it never really
occurred to me to say like why does a
kitty pryde just remove him out of the
adamantium and it's cool because like
when she sits down and does is it's not
like a simple thing right it's not like
I MacGuffin like Oh Wolverines and
adamantium well we'll just pull him out
done like it's if it doesn't work that
way instead like Kitty Pryde kind of
makes us this argument of like I can try
to get him out but there's no guarantees
he's got Wolverine in his arm so he's
got adamantium in his bones he's in the
case in adamantium being able to
differentiate between the body structure
of Wolverine and the adamantium encasing
him is gonna be incredibly hard and if I
screw up I'll tear him apart like I'll
start to pull him out and his upper body
will come out and he'll just have like
adamantium just kind of hanging out of
an adamantium case it's cool like it's a
really really genius and interesting
idea now ultimately she's able to pull
it off and she basically pulls Wolverine
out of the adamantium and they
essentially go through and just bury him
and that's what's awesome is because you
start having characters like Jubilee
these significant members dupe is their
goop is awesome those guys you don't
know who dupe is like he's a magic
Wolverine is the only person who
understands what dupe says like nobody
else understands what dupe says it's
he's weird he's like adorable and he's
like the most adorable creation ever but
like dupe is there and then you have
like you know the the main roster of
x-men that's something I want you to
notice here the x-men who were there are
by and large the ones that had the
biggest role in Wolverines life and
that's the whole point of this is to say
like this is a throwback to the old
x-men comics this is
basically giant-size x-men - like Angel
and Iceman and Jean Grey like that's
essentially what this is the original
giant-size x-men team and so it's
interesting to see this because
everybody's paying their respects
everybody's saying look you know we
didn't always see eye to eye we didn't
always agree with each other but at the
end of the day we had it where it counts
and so that's what ends up going on here
is is people begin sort of asking these
questions of like what's going on what
in the world is taking place like where
did Wolverine go like you know what
what's happening are the x-men again the
in the interior group of the x-men are
by and large aware of what's going on
but at this point like kind of jumping
back we end up having like this really
cool moment where Kitty Pryde is just
sort of sitting down and like talking to
the grave of rain remember this is not
just like a random thing they have a
long history together like Wolverine was
in a lot of ways a father figure for
Kitty Pryde and that's the way your
character was done back when Chris
Claremont introduced Kitty Pryde into
the x-men you had things like store who
taught her how to be a woman because
Kitty Pryde was kind of you know removed
from her family at a very very young age
when she was like 15 years old and so as
she was going through those
coming-of-age experiences that every
young person goes through storm helped
to guide her through all those things
that women need to come to grips with
about how their bodies work and then
Wolverine was more of a father figure
teaching her how to deal with like boys
and different things like that but it
was cool it was it was very much like
her being basically a child of the x-men
is really what it was but as she
basically pays her respect by pouring
Canadian beer on Wolverine which I don't
know why you would drink Canadian beer
but like pouring Canadian beer on
Wolverine she sees like the garb he was
wrapped in hanging on a tree and that's
when it kicks off that that's when she
realizes how could I have been so stupid
like how can I have been so dumb as to
believe this and so what we end up doing
it's basically like like picking up with
Wolverine himself just like trashing a
guy and then somebody simply responds by
saying that's enough like you don't need
to like you need to stop don't do
anything else like that's it and then
Wolverine is basically just sitting back
down again and so the result is that the
x-men essentially dig up the grave and
they realize Wolverines gone like he's
out of there no one knows where he's
gone to no one knows how he's out but
this is the important thing it looks
like either someone's training Wolverine
kind of like bringing him back to
society or someone's using Wolverine now
this would work all right a lot of
people would look at this and say really
someone is using Wolverine this is a
weapon again but it works because
Wolverine is rooted in that that's the
basis of his character
Wolverine wasn't always a member of the
x-men like Wolverine I mean he was born
in 1800 whatever and he fought in a
whole bunch of wars and when he got
involved in team
and he was part of like the the CIA
black ops team because of the fact that
he had a healing factor alongside
Sabretooth and like other members like
gray fox and so on and so forth they
were grabbed and they were thrown into
the Weapon X project and they were
basically used as weapons that was the
whole point
like Wolverine went on all these
different black ops Strikeforce missions
with Team X being used as a weapon to
topple governments to take out political
officials to eliminate political rivals
all kinds of different things like it
was all manner of ideas and then when he
eventually was rolled into the Weapon X
project he was used as a weapon under
Weapon X so I mean his whole life is
rooted in all that stuff it's rooted in
all those different things
I knew it makes sense that if Wolverine
came back even if only for a short
moment in time he's essentially being
turned into a weapon again this is going
to basically go in and coincide with the
little one-page back up features of all
these comics that explain where
Wolverines been what he's been doing
what's been happening behind the scenes
and how he managed to pick up the space
stone I think it is but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb pork
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]